une production du studio sf
bio venus au sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter des
super chaud quand tu es avec moi d'une
plante si vous écoutez le podcast
aujourd'hui vous êtes intéressé par
l'invité que d'hommes représenté dans un
instant ben ça chez vous peut le
rencontrer en personne en louant le
studio sf l'endroit où est ce qu'on se
trouve en ce moment on a trois studios
on à l'atelier dans lequel on se trouve
on a le boudoir c'est à peine si mon à
l'original que vous connaissez déjà si
vous avez un projet de podcasts d'un
projet d'audi au bouquet projet de web
séminaires un projet de jeu de rôle un
projet de ce que vous voulez vous allez
voir le site internet du diocèse points
c'est à vous écrire et on s'occupe de
tout se tenant dans les grands manitous
cette semaine on reçoit le grand manitou
du studio sf le mystérieux nicole
peut-être que vous savez même pas de
quoi y aller parce que des fois on
entend sa voix et fonde en parlait
toujours derrière la caméra on le voit
rarement et bien là on passe un podcast
complet avec lui on a discuté du studio
de discuter lui ont discuté de podcasts
ait pas de casse de la teinte de caisse
et des sujets qui nous intéressent mais
tanaka on a parlé autour de
rétrospectives de l'historique du studio
fille de l'historique de ce merveilleux
nicole cet employé si cher à nos coeurs
que sans lui rien de tout ceci
n'existerait donc vous voulez découvrir
un peu plus de ce mystérieux c'est la
pire pour rebondir vous allez comprendre
en nectar podcast pour rebondir sur
quelque chose qui cite cependant podcast
fait le genou et joss dray fait le fait
que vous avez à faire la guerre
faites-le qui n'allait jamais le
regretté fait sans plus attendre à voir
merci nom commence par et après surfer
ou blessent ou pas de casque bonne copie
quant à katie le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté par nos amis chez oh
les cas canevas quitte une compagnie qui
fait des canevas sur mesure 100 % au
québec on a fait affaire avec eux pour
faire la décoration du studio sfr offre
plusieurs services ailleurs sur leur
site qui après de canevas fait avec des
artistes des artistes locaux vous pouvez
même faire votre propre canevas en drag
and drop une image sur leur site web et
le faire et la faire imprimer mais il ya
aussi un service offert aux entreprises
que nous on a utilisé en fait qui nous a
permis de faire une déco est un opus
pour tous nos studios sont venus ici
regardez les lieux regardez la vague est
imprégnée de l'esprit l'espace on aurait
dit qu'est ce qu'on imaginait aussi
puis ils ont fait des cadeaux sur mesure
avec leurs artistes maison donc c'est
des oeuvres originales qui existe juste
ici alors si dans la tête de ceux dont
on se trouve on ne se croit yable
canevas qui avait dans tous les locaux
dans l'espace comme une de nos studios
ça l'a vraiment améliorée en fait mots
de ph en dépôt les dieux de la déco
n'est pas si mal mon épaule et du la
déco non plus ça a vraiment a rajouté
une touche vraiment
incroyable et tard acheter encore plus
de 20 dans les patios même décontraction
comme celui que j'ai dans mes mains en
ce moment qui sont disponibles sur leur
site web donc si vous n'êtes pas inspiré
pouvait aller voir des inspirations sur
leur site web mais on a un code promo
pour vous qui le sans filtre 15 pour 15%
rabais c'est la meilleure offre qui est
disponible pour l'instant pour olé
canevas honnêtement aller voir leur site
le lien va être dans la destruction du
podcast fille on est vraiment vraiment
content du partenariat qu'on a avec eux
parce que toutes nos canevas dans tout
les studios sont parfaits son idéal on
est extrêmement content merci la gagne
dans le caca et vous chez vous allez
voir ce we
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oye
ya personne n'y a personne qui est au
courant de tout seul mais à toutes les
fois que je rentre dans le studio ouais
j'ai tout un accueil comme ça
nicole est devenu unis qui au fil du
temps devenu toutes sortes afin d'y
question aux hôtes le web
qui manie qui dans toute ma vie le
journal ne porte le monde avec juillet
personne qui m'a jamais appelé ni qui
sauve ou deux l'autre jour et les filets
sexuelle et à une autre étape une équipe
il faut
soigner aller mais ça se peut que
les gens ont aimé le terrain d'une
légende qui puis à l'aube de notre
200ème épisode
200ème épisode sans faille à son
objectif enfin d'amazonie qui parce que
nicky tout est dit à quel épisode qui
était rentré sur le podcast qui est
bâtie dans ce cas c'est qu'elle a
quittée l'épisode est venu au début je
pesais cqn numéro gens mais cela
l'épisode à calais et champagne c'est le
premier que te fait avec nous la
première fois qu'ils viennent
gratuitement
les 45 ou 50 cas je pense puis avec
champagne seul
puis le deuxième le deuxième c'est lui
avec les ongles 1-1 puis dans le
deuxième c'est là que la foi de nicole
avait embarqué le suisse qui en fait la
première fois je m'étais pointé le jour
du podcast alexandre champagne je me
rappelle de tout qui mavuba rapport le
tapis était venu être autonome fait une
demande sur pétrole sur nous-mêmes
pétrone pour savoir qui allait venir
nous aider gratuitement
tout avec avait accepté tu étais venu te
dire moi je vais être le 6 et était
rentré en studio puis le jeu marvel puis
par exemple ben j'étais roi gt gt est
rentré dans le studio plus tu savais pas
trop comment jean laborde et a duré fait
juste tout juste 10 h salle unique nico
nico je sais pas comment tu veux qu'on
qu'on présente comme un conte appel puis
pis monsieur justin johnston et on sera
encore là mais ce jeu qui m'a j'ai fait
comme glenn s'arrêter ou jacques et que
je représente que nicole en partant du
fait que sa juste part simone mais
apprécions la faute aux podcasts avec
avec alec champagne puis ses yeux rien
de
ma vie pas fait d'accord que ce soit à
lahti savais juste que ne passe inaperçu
mais le deuxième podcast la deuxième
fois que j'étais venu se déleste avec
les en lisant dans les zones qui
revenait des d'irlande qui revenait de
voyage
pileux avant qu'ils en arrivent le on
s'était dit jean lieu avant qu'ils
n'arrivent on essaie de présenter comme
nicole puis on essaie de rester sérieux
le titre can't croates ou qui sait on
avait échoué comme lamentablement c'est
en fait tout est très bon c'est
j'ai toujours jamais une mise en ont
plus le même qu'en cas quand on reçoit
des merdes pour des nouveaux clients
potentiels au studio jr vous allez être
accompagné par nos techniciens en
parenthèse nick
wey qui épie mai mais ouais moi j'ai
jamais une mesure non plus j'ai juste
que tu lâches mr et dopent la
demande d'ici l'été pivot du sort toute
sa sérénité j'appuyais bonjour menicon
pigeât les autres comme des comme si de
rien n'était mais aujourd'hui c'est pour
moi mettons aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
la deuxième nation c'est normal
s'il ya du monde this plus au studio là
et il ya du monde des foyers
change mon nom mais non normativement va
voir un show maintenant avec du monde kg
rencontre au studio c'est nicole et moi
fait que ces sorties un peu en dehors du
studio 6 mai mais ce qui est encore le
monde qui font un contre un deux
secondes d'hésitation de fortis et
nicole
j'arrive au début au début je mélange
les genres je faisais juste arrêté avec
ma place je fais je le dire les choses
comme non c'est pas mon vrai nom mais
tout le monde m'appelle de même si
depuis longtemps fixé
me rappelle c'est le 1 des programmes
podcast le plus
pour le plus important mais le plus
ancien que le plus impressionnant c'est
daniel bélanger conseiller de le quesnoy
de loin le terrain idéal pour
- pillot québec
cahill round fait juste dire salut moi
c'est nicole plus tard garthby
sa fille nine mais me pose pas de
questions mais séquence an mal an il est
en train de parler à juliette sa fille
se pose est allé chercher au plein effet
combien l égorgement n'ai fait que les
innus a lutté près tout dit plainte et
regarde fais tout ton nom c'est si
nicole powell c'est nicole bricq sommes
un peu mais les prêts dit à sa fille au
téléphone un scud moi je pense en train
de même pas niaiser
m je pense que je tendrais n'aime pas
niaiser voir ces gars là que j'ai
rencontré le 2 heures que j'ai passés
kindia ou kindschi mèche mais j'ai
toujours trouvé ça dort j'ai toujours
trouvé ça drôle puisque pour ce qui est
juste comme embarqué à fond là-dedans
l'intimé mais général marche le monde se
pose moins de questions n'intéressent
plus les
c'est bon c'est un peu la généralisation
mal et pluvieux mais tous ceux qui le
souhaitent un arrêt au studio médecins
selon qu'ils émanent est
un exemple un exemple qui est bon je me
rappelle plus de son nom un animateur tv
le folkeniii servi au studio juste après
jean-luc mongrain ma clinique eaaci
[Rires]
était venu sur le pad 15 et jay était
venu sur le podcast de jaypee est arrivé
d'avant ce budget est pas là encore fait
club jose avec quelle rencontre
incongrue quand même toi tu es le il ya
éric duhaime puits
sapele asti mark boal or marc boilard et
rick james sûrs dans le studio toi tu es
le jean luc mongrain harry en attendant
j'ai du temps
c'était bon mais bref si je me rappelle
je m'appelle mal présentée comme nicole
probablement à jean luc mongrain pis
village j'ai vu très clairement je ne
croyais pas ou quelque chose comme cela
fait fait léger diwan matisse mais plein
de monde qui m'appelle n'importe comment
tes mains du monde qui m'appelle nikki
plus on a juste j'ai jusqu'à l'os une
même mission dans l'univers messieurs
dans l'univers puis on a continué jazz
et puis c'est pas dix minutes plus tard
magna comme un nicky qui est sorti
du cerveau comme genre a fait le saut un
peu mais je peux
ça devait être je m'appelle à ce moment
là en plus parce que c'est mais target
québec le personnage éric duhaime s'est
quand même montré que ces crabes lé dans
sap a pas nécessairement je suis
persuadé qu'il est beaucoup plus nuancé
dans la vie de tous les jours que le
personnage qu'incarne qu'en quittant
radio le je trouve ça un gros problème à
québec mais ce podcast le qui était venu
faire
avec mark boal or c'est la seule fois
que c'est arrivé dans l'histoire du
studio est ce qu'on avait écrit à
la marque mab alors qu'ils nous avaient
écrit pour faire on veut passer ce
podcast en studio je sais qui tu es venu
pilet avec un excédent vidéo devant
notre logo le ft le monde arabe pas
porter le masque de la manif estime
c'est comme ces saillies seront là les
gorges a posté sur son facebook l'argent
il ya quand même fait une vidéo facebook
s'était pas toi qui filmait oust et marc
bolland qui finançait je lui faisais un
truc c'était genre c'est saïd il ya eu
tellement aller à une manif anti masque
à québec devant no logo classique mais
non mais
non c'est à quelque chose de pas de cash
flow s'y met y aura un autre pas de cash
pense qu'on en fait je sais pas si c'est
aux autres leur avait dit comme qu'on
voulait plus faire sécher noir si
c'était un autre qui était juste parvenu
mais je m'appelle y avait un autre pas
de casse wild un peu dans le même temps
que ce genre d'info d'ebola oui
ou
non il le concède
qu'il leur avait crié je pense aux
autres et il y avait juste était juste
parvenus le mois mais leur concept était
maigre bilan
il voulait faire genre de débat autour
de la cage vide en tant que ça a
commencé le tir je pense qu'on venait
juste de rouvrir sauf que c'était
vraiment pour des bleus s'est limitée
d'accord finalement les deux tu es
d'accord
mais
je faisais les rues script de terre mais
c'était comme jouer je ressentais
vraiment jouer mais en même temps il y
avait fort c'est leur affaire parce que
s'il y avait des tas mettons de réponse
pour chacun des deux bords avec ma tante
avait une minute mettons pas la personne
qui était pour le masquer une minute
entre image qui fait système c'était
vraiment genre c'était comme tout
s'était pour que ça ait de loire le plus
neutre possible mais comme je te l'aï
joly c'était sa part si la personne qui
était tout le temps mais tant pour le
masquer c'est un script et c'est affable
qui allait les arguments de marbre tout
le temps tu fais ça paraissait sa part
et si tu sors un podcast en direction
anti masque anti modo sanitaire déguisée
sous un faux débat où est ce que tout le
monde est anti mesures sanitaires il y
en a une qui jouent des arguments
mauvais ce site est
comme le m'en foutais fille puis au
début je trouvais ça oui mais même si je
m'appelle je vous en avais parlé la
raison pour que je vous en ai parlé en
fait parce que les autres je pense qu'il
voulait faire leur propre montage nous a
dit qu'il y en a enregistré comme plus
de temps qu'il voulait comme raccourcir
sa après
mais
j'ai perdu mon idée
mais même si tu nous avais écrite je
pense que finalement été jamais revenu
c'est parce que après le podcast au
restaurant j'ai entendu aux lettres
compris
l'espace les deux animateurs qui
s'occupait de gérer ce genre de
discussion là dans le fond qui était
clairement gentil
tout noter enfin fait cela c'est là que
j'ai vu j'ai comme compris que qui est
clairement j'aurais ces puits connaissez
maintenant la fille qui était comme anti
mesure où il en connaissait déjà qui est
l'autre connaisseurs permet - carmat
fait que c'était comme ça me rappelle
pas de calais j'étais sûr que c'était
très fort
rêveur gossip qui avait évité un goût
pour parler de la 5 juillet puis avait
dit genre fokine des trucs du genre
moi je m'en suis même pas rendu compte
de ce que j'avais même pas entendu
parler de la 5e je pense avance de
podcasts le fac lui est arrivé le lustre
comme un docteur je vois trop l'utilité
y avait quand même des causes études
puis moi j'écoutais ça puis je lis kulka
vraiment puisque j'avais géré
mentalement voyez ce genre qu'est ce que
j'avais fait dans vos sites comme elle
en plus en plus je pense que le gars en
question qui avait loué si tu te rends
pas son intention que de faire un genre
de podcasts controversé le je pense
qu'ils voulaient juste qu'on me donne la
parole un peu à quelqu'un qui avait une
idée sur le côté que lui même été
surpris de ce qui est arrivé pendant son
podcast puiqu'il eu malgré tout mis en
ligne mes soucis mais un métier mais
même étendu dans vraiment que même une
autre on aurait pu comme ben oui ça
c'est bien expliqué que cela ça va il
d'avoir raison c'est cela qui fait
exact ce système qui sera dans le le
scientifique le chercheur qui te
regardent mais guil monsieur journaux
et vous pourrez pas les rousses et ce
exactement à faire parler après ça avec
avec lui bernard
à quelle drôle
drôle de période c'est nous autres on a
au moins la chance de pouvoir
sélectionner les projets qui on
travaille c'est ce qu'on est on se donne
nombre on se donne cette liberté-là
laitiers on est une compagnie privée on
pousse tous points aux émeutes et en
même temps tout le monde peut mais on
laisse vraiment l'attitude seror quand
on n'a jamais
vu ça on époque comme tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer moi j'avais fera
pourtant pas le cas avec toi tu peux pas
parler mais mais oui il ya eu une
période où est ce qu'il y avait beaucoup
de trucs des fois qu'ils venaient
question
c'est qu'il y avait aussi s'il y avait
une pandémie mondiale
faisaient c'était quand même
devenir une jarre de sources de comme
des informations mais en même temps tu
veux aussi laissé parce que l'idée
démocratiser la conversation
initiale du studio effective et laisser
le plus de l'os possible c'est comme si
tu joues et que ceux ci c'est l'espèce
de
de lame à double tranchant des podcasts
lundi parce que le podcast la meilleure
chose parce que justement ça permet
d'avoir des conversations en avance sur
toutes sortes d'affaires est vraiment
aidé en profondeur des trucs parler
librement de ce qui se faisait à la main
mais
ça peut faire des
organes fédéraux guen moi je dirais le
type
de règles j'écoute juste plus métier
tenta je vois des clés passer maintenant
le des suggestions eu toujours des
sujets qui sont paumés tant les sujets
signifie que les sujets projecteurs il
parlait de la limite de la sla petit jus
ce qu'ils disaient tout genre font son
texte sur l'événement mushtaqun afin que
le fait du sens auprès de la sphère
trouve que
si tu décides invités du monde pour
parler de trucs scientifiques mettent
pas tout le temps celui qui quitte seul
à penser sur versus les 99% qui ont un
consensus
il ya comme un
comment un danger là dedans surtout
quand kate un aussi gros ses fans
puisque ceux ci comment être le problème
aussi sexy c'est que ces indépendants la
plupart des projets de podcasts et oui
les studios de podcasts petite bourgogne
est acheté par spa les failles mais ça
reste des projets indépendants affectés
et comme personne en haut qui vient dire
quelque chose je dis les commanditaires
peuvent ne pas vouloir s'associer à toi
mettons aussi ça leur appartient à eux
mais c'est à des commanditaires wheeling
qui sans colistier john logan ne prend
le maquis commanditaires peu importe le
tec pioche on importe qui a la force et
commanditaires c'est comme si moi en
vendent la poudre d'athlétiques green
tic puis pitre comme personne en haut il
n'y a pas de délai mains et comme
ses collègues l'expression que cherche
des fois d'instance de l'utilisation en
aussi quelques personnes qui décident ce
genre tu peux dire ce que tu veux puis à
personne c'est au contraire mettons sur
ce qu'ils radio can le ton et audio de
l'application balade aux autres joueuses
autant aux qu'ils font quand même son
peuple les avocats qui check raiser qui
ont été corrects mais des fois même sa
fin le team mettons tous ravis qu'on a
reçues podcast puis du monde que les
yeux de moins qu'ils écrivent as
personnes le sk dit c'est pas fondées
sur ce final en a mais ce monde le sont
à razouk un
bain sharks cus mountain est une équipe
de troyes jean bizet un no 1 au portugal
les plus controversées qu'on a fait
c'est un grand honneur fut plus de
commentaires négatifs mettons c'était
avec jean philippe wauthier inde est
sûre le tout les segments qu est ce qu
on voit ce qu'ils parlent de nutrition
pitié jaune interminable ces choses-là
métier georges flagothier
littéralement partout et ce qui peut
être lu comme un atout clé toutes les
grosses d'instance crédible et partout
puis ce pas de casque la cause car on
est sur youtube que tout le monde donne
son opinion mais on se fait ramasser
parce qu'on traite le sujet qu'on en a
partout non plus pour par les matons de
skanès m'annoncer sa exact qu'on casse
annoncée c'est exact du sport un
personnage controversé de balancer
jusqu'à l'oeil comme est tanné
connaissons un podcast
dix affaires qui ont déplu à certains
personne ne
fait la ville et ses collègues des
critiques avec dadis qu'on veut discret
que les gens crise et enfin la ville
c'est ça la vie c'est sur la vie on a la
liberté dans le fond c'est semaine
vivent au québec en alberta on veut
quelqu'un la liberté de ce qu'ils
veulent sur puis enfin elle voter qui
qu'on veut aussi mathieu maton parvenir
joe higgins et ses matons l'argument de
comme je peux inviter maintenant à
n'importe qui pour représenter ma tombe
les différents points de vue un peu
d'annulations match comme c'est oui sauf
que ça reste que c'est invite quelqu'un
m'a t'on kiki qu'est ce qu'ils disent et
j'ai racheté par 99% maintenant de
la communauté scientifique séparatistes
beach s'est passé pour un point de vue
qui peut durer
parce que je veux croire celui là fait
connaître la personne qui va arriver
offrir la personne que tu fais ce que tu
veux ce qui est encore plus aussi touché
des fois c'est sur soi quelqu'un parce
qu'ils y y jeter n'importe quoi le
champion de skate board plus tu
l'invités pantois pas risquer bord
pendant deux heures le sort décide à
faire
le travail
on y peut littéralement rails mais on
met le paquet complet physique ou die
les ex il faut quoi ils viennent dire
une énormité genre sont en dépôt qu'on
aille l'homme et lyon en italie qu'est
ce qu'on fait
c'est de la pisse tranquillement ouais
ouais parce que c'est ça on est un peu
aussi tous les genres de directeur de la
conversation le tri fait qu'amener fodil
et avec les cartes construit
plus de fois où est-ce qu'on était là on
a vu quelqu'un pour parler de quelque
chose de complètement différente
l'amener aux pentes en donnant quelque
chose ce genre
je t'aime allait vraiment à côté du
consensus
si on dit rien
mais quoi
vous êtes bien débrouillé malgré tout là
dedans je trouve tes m'attendre vos
opinions seraient certains thèmes
mettons centrale ou sans trop en faire
des sons sont assez claires ne sais pas
si on vous suit le dépôt de 400 pas de
casse on comprend généralement assez
bien c'est quoi vos opinions sais pas si
on a reçu beaucoup et on a fait quand
même beaucoup cas sur la nutrition matin
qu'
on a reçu du monde qui ont des opinions
vraiment différente je pense le sur ce
même sujet le mais au final je pense que
si on les écoute votre de votre opinion
est claire mais c'est ça le problème
parce que mettons
si tu nous suit mes tantes est capable
de savoir si maintenant quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui écoute et les 200 épisode
du podcast le hic c'est que moi je chute
un gode gauche principalement mais que
j'ai quand même décidé peut-être
conservatrice dans certains certaines à
partir de mon mac adresse car même film
est 4e juste quelque chose au retour
mais ton je me rappelle à mais je pense
que c'était le podium en effet avec le
maire de laval où est ce que on est on
parle de la loi 21 l'immigration et puis
moi je suis pas nécessairement d'accord
à 100% avec avec son point de vue c'est
le documentaire c'était jean rouaud ph
mathieu bock côté d'or les gros apport
plan boy juste un gars qui répondent
comme si pht clairement god gauche pique
sommes ouverts d'esprit pis limite au
hockey
tu le compares à mathieu bock-côté on a
quand même un problème de compréhension
mais en même temps dans ce podcast le
c'est sûr que t'as pas tout mon petit
pas tout les le parcours intellectuel
que j'ai fais pitié que qu'on peut voir
maintenant le tiff équipe a quelque
chose dans le contexte plus que moi mais
si c'est ça ça des palais où se situe la
personne qui écoute et parce que si mes
temps de personnes qui écoutent déjà à
une extrême d'un du spectre d'un gauche
droite mais là c'est sûr que c'est ce
même si tout est à gauche mais ce petit
plus à droite qui est que ces personnes
là que pour elle il n'y a pas de
distinction à moins que mathieu bock
côté
la droite
un bon sens et bon sixième sens des
caisses qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ça à filtre oui l'été évidemment
qu'ils étaient on dit ce qu'on parle
qu'on dise qu'on veut mais genre
si aussi que les des trucs une scène qui
ferait que genre ça passerait peut on y
pense toujours qu'on pense pas que c'est
comme se mettra pas naturellement la
barbarde métier ça peut arriver défaut
qui est invité je commence quelque chose
puisque comme
on vous proposait cette personne le
peut-être way unissent l'arrivée ouais
c'est arrivé qu'on a devant nous inviter
en j'enlèverai soeur connaissent un
destin se rappelle de pop kiev le
quelques semaines
c'était comme ça se voit recevoir une
coudée message là dessus
ouais mais on n'a pas fait beaucoup de
monde a pas de gaz pas le fait souvent
qu'on a enlevé des goudes non en fait je
suis un peu de cash pense mais ton qui
est que je me rappelle qui a
dernièrement on a dû enlever une coupe
de faire médecine on y en a qu'on a
enlevé un bon but quand même
mais jusqu'où plus je peux vraiment plus
dans sexe
est
une merde ça nous a coûté un système
sans fil mais toto pas trop peur de nous
de nous penser ça shakeel mais s'exalte
écoute tout le temps pour rester alerte
mettons seals marque 6 10 moi j'ai pas
le choix gg je n'ai juste pas le choix
mais mathieu ils me le disent tout le
temps aussi les faits par après puis si
je perds je leur envoie le podcast le
tchèque et othman qu'est-ce qui veut qu
est ce qu écrit mais voit quasiment dans
chaque épisode il ya tout temps au moins
un line up thien ah koon parce que si
s'est rendu
dans le temps me semble juste vous
écoute le tiff le le genre 4 4,5 m salim
djouab et mène à renfoncer conter des
histoires vraiment personnel sont du
monde tout ça c'est quand même calmé je
pense en général d'un podcast parce que
à manille le monde se rend compte que tu
peux tu peux pas tu peux juste pour
faire beau juste dire n'importe quoi sur
n'importe qui publiquement à puteaux au
début c'était quelque chose de vraiment
ni je suis vraiment comme
pas deux grands métiers
am a rejeté les podcasts puis j'en
retiens plus son monde en soi mais genre
de plus en plus ça devient c'est de quoi
de de légitime un peu comme le
fait qu 6ème année s'il monte ils disent
n'importe quoi en faire mais même mike
est allé à tous moi par mes pieds pour
parler de toute écoute justement puis du
succès de ses coûts depuis dix ans si le
monde s'il ya quelqu'un qui prenait
vraiment la peine d'écouter toutes les
épisodes se découdre avec un calepin ont
pu noter que les affaires que les gens
ils pourraient avoir des chars des
disputes le autour c'est quand il y en a
à l'infini genre cédé 2 heures de
personnes plus chaudes qui fait qu'on
l'annonçait mais je peux bien sûr que
maintenant le monde ils font plus
attention je suis aussi des fautes il
montre andy d'affaires hors contexte
effrontée genre facile quand même
terville et moi même mais en partie
aussi je pense que
la technologie s'est développé autour
des podcasts annoncé avant c'était
beaucoup du monde faisait des affaires
peu chez eux j'appuie un peu bobo chez
tout fait je pense aussi que le monde
s'en foutait un peu plus tandis que le
tout s'est organisé c'est tout si on a
trop studio le ici aux normes et tout et
tout et tout et tout et plus propre il
veut repos je pense que je pense que
vous aussi que
ça fait juste démontrer en fait qu'elle
et les médiums ça devient de plus en
plus sérieuse et puis devient et un
impact en fait surtout sous écoutes
laissent un impact
je pense que peut-être le monde font
plus attention mais faut quand même pas
perdre l'attrait principal du départ qui
était justement des gens c'est plus
naturel c'est plus libre c'est plus
qu'une conversation comme tu es dans ton
salon mais ça va toujours
pour ce type de beaucoup de cas de shu
pas de casque qui vont se développer
dans les prochaines années
exact c'est beaucoup aussi totale émise
et retient qui commencent à s'intéresser
vraiment plus est cette forme là aussi
parce que je pense que justement c'est
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit pas
ailleurs
c'est quoi annoncer ça évolue ça évolue
non-stop l'époque c'était pas ça qu'on a
commencé 200 épisodes ça a tellement
changé elles savent ça fait trois ans et
plus qui quand ils me c'est fou comment
ça change et autres c'est comme est en
fait très peu de casse toi qui as le
genre des jeux d'outreau qui existent
mène plus que ce métier
c'est à la mode n'était pas au genre
remontaient pastèque ou des podcasts
comme tout le monde
des milliers de podcasts
ouais je m'en rends compte si le terrain
il y en a sur littéralement tout les
sujets départagera d'arpenteur
puis en fait
je ce que je me rends compte c'est quel
est
l'attrait de d'enregistrer les podcasts
c'est beaucoup c'est les contacts que tu
te fais au final puis au début c'était
beaucoup les podcasts dans culture comme
tel puisque c'était ce qui était payant
pour les view sur un petit mais le tout
à des entrepreneurs qui viennent là qui
commence dans leur milieu des jeunes
entrepreneurs qui sont capables d'avoir
comme des françois lambert mende
rongeurs ou cdd gros entrepreneurs
vraiment établie depuis longtemps puis
qui apprécieront leur numéro de
téléphone genres et tous ont leurs
contacts parce qu'ils ont su sur des
podcasts parce que c'est du monde qui
sont pas nécessairement habitués d'aller
sur des podcasts mangent à leur caf etc
sont contents de le faire s'ils sont
contents le faire quand il quatre
camions à l'invitation c'est quoi enfin
que fax et ses supports payants l'eau
financée pour des pour des entrepreneurs
c'est tellement
le jeu ça va sonner comme une peu pour
le studio cyr plusieurs parts et vos
podcasts lemay méthode allées dallées
développer une relation de proximité
avec la clientèle c'est vraiment super
important puis cité clients écoute ton
podcast vont sentir tellement plus
proche de la compagnie puis bon
d'helmand rester longtemps avec toi que
ça en vaut la peine c'est pis pour
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui enregistre
ici maintenant le titre se soit jamais
ton il ya 2 coach privé je pense qu
ankara geste ici le
oui deux non mais c'est comme un podcast
ou ski cd comme des coachs le
puits et autres d'avoir maintenant un
nouveau client
pour leur pratique
qui va s'entraîner avec eux trois
semaines ne tombe injuste pour un client
ça rembourse les frais du podcast fait
que genre pour aller chercher des
nouveaux clients c'est tellement bon pit
souvent besoin juste d'avoir un ou deux
nouveaux clients puis tu vas souvent en
avoir beaucoup plus que cela sauf que
juste ça ça rentable et son truc fait
comme si c'est pour ce pour ça que ça
vient ça disparaîtra sans pitié par pour
revenir sur les podcasts plus nuage issu
de quoi qui est vraiment super niche je
pense pas qu'on pourrait partir le sans
filtre aujourd'hui puis avoir connaître
le même succès la même croissance parce
que des podcasts des gens qui parle à
des gens
il y en a mais nous y en aa les fils tu
vas voir une entrevue ti au début mais
ton
gabriel nadeau-dubois qu'un conte leur
su le la deuxième podcast
il n'y avait jamais parlé pendant une
heure une heure vingt de façon
décontractée casualty maintenant tu veux
écouter un podcast via bruno dubois via
un anneau crise mais ces mêmes en fait
toutes les éviter qu'on recevait afin de
chaque podcast il déjà est ce la
première fois que je fais ça visant un
public amateur
jarty site montrent que les gens
suivaient mais ça prend faut que je les
entends parler tu es vraiment
naturellement comme se rendre et je la
découvre une belle façon de
rapports le puits proximité le à
la rue on est une personne aujourd'hui
des personnes plus derrière la dans son
côté comme comme agent serait un super
ami c'était comme pas quelque chose qui
était normal de voir ton avis envoyer
les gens à tv ou des 10-15 minutes
métier soit il joue un rôle ou sous
sénart d'entrevue spar série pneus nana
mais là c'est comme c'est comme nouveau
puisque comme jean roy c'est ce
affective des conversations même je
pense pas qu'on est capable d'avoir des
tirs de relancer un projet de même avec
ce que souhaitent maintenant des
podcasts niches soit parce qu'il faut
que tu fasses tu veux faire quelque
chose du moins je pense le
lieu où il à faire les podcasts mettons
plus plus générale c'est un truc mais il
ya la façon de le faire son actrice puis
mouvement a nettement au dessus je t'ai
je vous en avais déjà parlé mais le sans
filtre je trouve que pas d'autres pas de
gaz qui peut reprendre cette place là en
ce moment je vis des podcasts une vague
des pacages genre de tous les sujets de
chrysler il y en a eu beaucoup mais je
mets chauds moment et à ce jour et puis
j'en ai écoutés en tabarnak
depuis dans les dernières années mais ça
reste qu'il n'y avait pas de podcasts
pour moi qui à ce stade ci prend encore
la place qu'elle son filtre fois que je
pense aussi que la façon de la faire
fait en sorte que même si tu feras pas
de casse plus générale
si tu cites un angle un peu une habituée
à ta sauce un petit thé quand même
capable de faire de quoi de bon genre
tout est dans la question de langue
quand même parce que de l'anglais par
don et non de la langue mais c'est
justement on a parlé dernièrement de
tout le monde ça il le podcast qui a
gagné le vivier du but du meilleur
podcast humoristique et méritait bien
mérité un autre le tien des podcasts
d'humour il ya un homme n jorgan à
l'infini c'est tout les humoristes et
leurs cousins ont un podcast maintenant
puis
mais eux ils ont fait ce sauf qu'ils
sont arrivés avec un concept de ganache
à quétigny revenir devant les autres
zimmermann c'est quoi c'est quoi tes
complexe puis on va en parler vont les
déconstruire j'ai trouvé ça magnifique
de ce concept lot effet qui ont pris un
concept qui calanques et des humoristes
qui improvise un peu ce qui est monnaie
courante mais on va mettre un twist qui
est vraiment intéressant puisqu'il va te
faire entendre quelque chose que les
gens n'ont jamais entendu tir parce que
des histoires mettons de jeu c'est pas
le jouer je vous dirai
sans breton mettons qui qui raconte une
anecdote il s'est investi mon compteur
c'est drôle son anecdote tu as entendu
le tir sauf que leurs 600 membres dont
il veut s'asseoir sur tout le monde
saillie qui raconte de quoi qui est un
complexe jamais entendu ceci c'est là
l'intérêt de ce genre de truc leur
sa demeure et c'est pas un podcast qui
nichent le tout le monde sait y ont sans
cesse espère que sa cible de tout le
monde peut écouter ce pareil c'est juste
que c'est
l'information que terre soir à danser
pas d'informations tailleur fixer ce
mois je pensais tu aperçois sacrée
lancés pour faire les bons pas de cas
cela je pense que c'est juste d'aider de
trouver trouver sa propre sur elle à
petit ça
aussi c'est que les conversations même
si sur tout cas que c'est vraiment
maintenant comme nous autres postscript
et puis c'est sans vraiment lignes
directrices 30 ans claude landry
précieux si nous aussi le pays qui
produit qui nous viennent c'est
tellement la personne qui était si ton
podcast
renseignements liés à la personne qui
est et remplace les personnes qui
animent je mets deux autres personnes
ici je ne sais pas mais ça c'est un
filtre situe sans titre
c'est tu peut imiter le concept liste
veut dès qu'ils quittent
mais sauf que ça va au final différents
on prend une petite pause du podcast
pour vous parler d'un master de la
journée qui est olic à nouveau oui et
elle va avec qui on a travaillé
directement conjointement sont venus ici
ont regardé les lieux ils ont fait des
canevas personnaliser la décoration
vraiment magnifique c'est des oeuvres
uniques existe juste ici et ils peuvent
faire la même chose pour vous pour votre
entreprise pour votre maison et il ya
aussi plein des canaux disponibles sur
leur site dans le style que vous voulez
donc c'est vraiment il y en a pour tous
les goûts avec week end vous pouvez même
faire votre propre canevas si vous avez
une image que vous aimez la photo de
votre grand-mère que vous voulez faire
imprimer un canevas mais vous pouvez la
faire sur leur site web si vous voulez
travailler avec leurs artistes de vous
pouvez le faire également pour chaque
assassine toile qui est disponible sur
leur site web une collaboration avec
symons honnêtement nous on a adoré cette
petite toile qui nous ont donné un
cadeau plus et c'est une des raisons qui
ont décidé de travailler avec eux pour
tout le reste vous allez voir dans les
packs à ce duo sf dans tout les studios
ya des nouvelles toiles de nouveau
canevas ben si l'éthique en mode all
canevas et pour chaque can vins vendus y
plantent un arbre ça fait plus de
bientôt vingt mille arbres qui ont vendu
en deux ans donc si vous voulez en plus
contribué à planter des heures des
arbres bien on a un code promo pour vous
qui le sans-fil truc 15 15 % de rabais
habiter dans un endroit où est ce que la
décoration est en pointe ça change tout
ça change littéralement tout être plus
heureux d'arriver chez vous je le sais
pour un fait trop longtemps encore
aujourd'hui je décore pas mais maison je
me sens jamais à la maison donc la
prochaine place que je déménage en
juillet je vais faire à faire encore une
fois avec les canes fois pour aller
chercher des cas devrait faire de ma
mère et de ma
make my house marron c'est sa
fête merci la gazelle canevas sans fil
dect ans pour 15 % de rabais puis on
retourne au podcast oui
nicole direct est devenu aussi une
légende le
régent de danse etc c'est un sex-symbol
de par six ex aval qui le deuxième
podcast originale du studio cif
mais qui étend pas de casse qui a
tellement explosé ça fait un petit peu
plus qu'un an quand on a lancé ça avec
les filles pieman s'est rendu le you
follow inculte le sexe oral j'ai jamais
vu quelque chose avec
avec autant d'engagement genre si
démesuré mais les filles sont tellement
bonne grâce à son incroyable moi je
trouve ce qui serait complète vraiment
bien voici ce qu'on peut vraiment bien
puis ils savent ce qu'ils font très tôt
tandis que
c'est johan y mettrons le des fois alala
un peu nonchalante sur le podcast les
petits c'est ce qui fait que c'est drôle
mais je pense moi je suis persuadé
joannie la maîtrise son truc là c'est
calme
concernant c'est un personnage très
authentique mais ces calculs et les
écoles à l'école de l'humour la rive le
puits est en mode performance noir puis
genre et que ça ça marche en estive
devant public le télé bougez jugement
lola aujourd'hui vu des vidéos devant
public le genre c'est que sa torche
comme hnc incroyable war et puis je me
rappelle justement là quand on est à
l'os à gauche les autres qu'à ce jour
les podcasts 27
26 au soir puis en 27 puis comme entre
les deux matonge en battant de mixer
je me rappelle la 26e georges wanis
genre deux ans avant d'en marquer que ma
pouvais pas croire qu'elles sont allées
de cette arrivée sur scène le petit
rimac ça a été la meilleure recette est
la meilleure
de nous quatre le à la torche est ce
vraiment le ccc logis c'est là j'ai vu
je pense à quel point est
vraiment
quelque chose qui s'est activé genre
juste avant d'entrer sur scène puis
qu'est la clenche et sur le sol est bon
match pour le
différent mais j'ai dit on des forces
plaideuse aussi des divisions la
sexualité d d d d d d expérience
différente d'une des valeurs différentes
ce qui fait que j'en tire c'est chaque
année quelques textures halki qui
fuiraient plus sa joie ni d'autres les
pénalisant depuis mai genre ça fait que
les lisent des piles et les versions au
plus vite sa sexualité sont représentés
également mettons tout le métier les
6-12 ce podcast le jeu j'ai quand même
des fois je réfléchis mais ton chez nous
je pense je pense à ce que je me dis
ça s'peut pas même je pense georges me
dit ça s'peut pas que ja
impunément
ce podcast le cfai en traitement des
jeux diront mais c'est l'effet y traite
de trucs qu'on n'a jamais entendu si je
veux juste prendre l'exemple du podium
jeu s'entend du jeu des enfants aux
archives a même promis
jusqu'à prendre l'exemple du podcast
qu'ils ont fait avec jo
jo suspend castellet ça va sortir
bientôt il est disponible sur itunes
abonnez-vous la gamme medios procas le
lin il raconte des orgies ou est ce qui
se fait sucer le baht par des gains puis
il raconte des affaires comme médecin
puis c'est comme pas assez sûr c'est que
ce genre à ces genres of course qui
raconte ce même pigeard l'autre comme
parce que je suis tombé sur un article
c'est le sac de chip qui comme un peu le
genre de journal à potins journal le
moral est haut comme sorte si genre
jonathan roy raconte des orgies des
parts et d'orgies en tournée
je vois ce passage fait comme
j'ai du monde que leur premier contact
avec le podcast sexuelles ces genres un
gros headliner de qom c'est pour nous
autres les juges à un autre épisode mais
il ya du monde c'est comme charge
directement par ces genres white shark
sais quoi qui sait où que tu peux
trouver ça puis on est vraiment un gros
spike dans les chu un spike dans les
membres piquionne après l'extrême et un
autre pack des membres et piquionne
après qu'il ya eu des articles qui est
partagé mais comme ce genre de sujet de
ce genre d'affaires le ca existe pas
même sa exploit qu'aucun média
traditionnel qui va accepter d'avoir une
conversation même sur leurs ongles aucun
même si ben trop cru c'est bien trop
hommes ces épiciers bonnes affaires
aussi est l'espèce d'être d'attrait
monétaire m'attends à ce qu'ils étaient
c'est que ça râle c'est quand l'ismans
écouter toutes les vidéos sont
démonétisé sur youtube n'est pas un
humain qu'on est capable d'aller
chercher derrière
le sud les sujets sur route puis il ya
quand même des buts i télé les podcasts
comme ça mais ton quand et cherchent ils
sortent pas en premier parce que son
démonétisé ce genre pour trouver 500
titres pour trouver sexe oral si tu
marques fcx même si pro allemand les
vidéos les plus écoutées de cette simple
hold your happy sera pas recommandée
genre faut que tu marques sexe oral pas
de calais cherche suis plus tard le
chercher puis il est écouté un exposé
des faits nous a promise et qu'ils ont
mis genre et à sa page d'accueil non non
c'est sa veine mais je trouve ça
tellement une scène parce que ça existe
pas mais le monde sont clairement le
monde sont intéressés puis va entendre
parler on parlait d t on parler devant
public puis je pensais être capable
d'aller à l'olympia où est ce qu'on
arrive en effet droit aussi puis le fait
en mode de bouffe est aujourd'hui mille
personnes
puis honnêtement je me disais sexe oral
following qui ont puis à l'intensité de
leurs fans mais tant qu'on disait le ont
fait une instit grosses salles en
annonçant six mois d'avancé quatre modes
avance avec l'art des special guest qui
a failli podcasts ont rempli une salle
de 1000 personnes sur basso
messieurs même si je faisais ça fait
vraiment vraiment vous a rejoint
littéralement tout le monde c'est la
sexualité humaine
mais le projet c'est que ça râle aussi
moi c'est le projet je me fait le plus
parler de loin si les demandes viennent
aux studios pixar il faut arrêter
nichols ex arast bien des photos etc
tout ça va ils prennent des photos avec
toi le score soit déjà et la voix ni que
le genre et le soir
c'était certainement oui parce que tim
thomas matton j'avais les filles
viennent enregistrer mais après c'est
une fois une fois que tout est fait il a
pas qu'à ses sorties le type une maison
en fait je m'en rends pas tant contre
mais je m'en fais tellement parlé je
m'en fais vraiment vraiment parlé
souvent qui même qui
s'est fait deux fois dans les deux
dernières semaines quelqu'un je m'envoie
dans un bar mais je me faire connaître
d'astor les jeux me faire connaître
pitié juge pourtant par sexuel oral de
ma face le signe + des excités qui sont
sortis que d'autres choses mais là ça
commence à arriver puis en plus je à
toutes les fois qu à toutes les fois
qu'elles changent tout le temps de
parler de la
fois que je pouvais pas ton amusé en
fait le job des approches mais fait
approcher par du monde random qui
viennent me parler
mais c'est foot et à quel point c'est à
dire est que dans ma tête je pensais pas
que ça avait tant d'ampleur que ce qui
met ça n'a
servi qu'à qu'on a
on a pas le retour tic est justement de
faire un shoot vendu mon sens des
retours étant donné tu vois le monde le
monde c'est comme si des commentaires
aussi des déchets ultimes et genre sa
peau le même rapport pigeât tout juste
est-il sans filtre tendance à oublier
aussi
andy mais l'impact
pigeât les deux derniers shows que j'ai
fait avec et ariane
un
premier show j'ai rien à voir à table de
meurtre à vendre des cd des délais après
arvier a dit chris tout le monde demande
d'une plante
le cheval cataldo marché
j'en revenais au temps mort qui est
excitant c'est son show puis le genre
j'écoute les pas de case qui le gèrent
ils veulent continuer la discussion non
ça fait fantasmer le podcast savard a
fait passer a dit d'en faire plus et
comme le o mensch parler qu'un groupe in
fi des comme la
situation politique au québec mais
ça m'est arrivé le exactement c'est moi
mettons mois le souhait que c'est fait
quand même le du monde qui me
reconnaissais préoccupations deux pays
comme les personnes qui me parle
d'occupation de petits le monde ce n'est
que du podcast pisser c'est le bienvenu
chaque fois quelques badauds et si vous
écoutez ses moyens mais veut nous parler
du podcast le cmfi oui ça me dérange
jamais mais déjà je n'ai acheté en
dessous de l'âge au canadien là je te
conter l'histoire du canadien le cheikh
amar shipping et à côté de moi qui comme
l'est le reaap la loge mettons là il
vient s'asseoir à côté biffé comme
shakespeare très professionnelle mais
j'écoute tous les épisodes ça fait pas
car on se met à parler qu'à midi quelque
chose qui m'a vraiment craint qu'il sait
le podcast de mathieu blanchard plomb se
met à parler de ce genre plonge le monde
revienne en plus le mousse mousse et
j'aurais le goût vient me voir dit
j'aimerais en podcast mais quant à dire
si guillaume du lieu j'étais comme déçu
de la tournure des événements
le monde si comme dit j'ai pas il ya
ceux qui restaient pris au piège
des cytises gens ça m'a rappelé et c'est
moi qui te regarde maman qui compte
c'est quand même puis changement je
pense en fait que j'allais qu'il va chez
creuse de plus en plus entre justement
les médias traditionnels puis le web
c'est dans ce sens que c'est moi
honnêtement je pense la majorité de mes
amis gens ont même pas
fait que sur le contenu qui écoute qui
consomment c'est le web sur le web à la
mode en ce moment c'est les podcasts une
s'est laissé les podcasts sfax et c'est
ça que mon écoute fait qu il ya toute
une génération que c'est sur le
communiqué que factice curieux et
maintenant devoir c'est parce que
maintenant laisser les stats de radio
ils sortent leur stade mais le cdsi
stade booster parce qu'il a trois corps
des gens sont dans leur show avec la
radio qui roulent mais le son a à [ __ ]
ici tout le temps disponible et écoute
m'étonne moi je serais curieux un christ
devoir mettons de comparer sexe oral à
genre une émission le
de grande écoute mettons de radio le
persuade que tu vois mettons toutes les
tout l'argent qui est quand comme une
émission de radio de deux produits sur
trois animateurs qui sont payés de le
plan alerte de toutes les start up et
les vendeurs de pub tout ça pour que
tout les peuples soient gonflés à bloc
puis après ça il ya rien dit il ça coûte
forking cher pour payer tout le monde
pour des écoutes qui sont boostés aussi
le tire vraiment curieux de faire vos
devoirs genre les écoutes world les
vrais écoute les gens qui portent
attention à ce qu'ils entendent à radio
versus le ton les chiffres de sexe oral
sur le sexe oral c'est vraiment vraiment
pas loin des grandeurs écoute de radio
mettons les grandes côtes d'écouté puis
je te garantis que pour une compagnie
qui n'ont sur le sexe oral ça coûte cole
et semant - chambre de couette
crissement plus précis que de payer
radio même pour des spots de 30 secondes
que le monde écoute polie mais oui pis
tu dois la devons vendre plus aussi je
pense qu'ils vont vendre plus parce que
le monde ou du moins ils vont vendre
pour l'heure pour eux pour leur argent
qu'ils dépensent ils vont vendre car
l'espace déjà fait 1 h et j'aurais
impulser ce jour du coup nous avons
entendu un radio paradiso impulsif mais
ramener
le produit maintenant tu vois ces jeunes
fondation savart groupe participe pas à
cause à cause de la pub traditionnelle
qui ont fait de bonnes idées afin de
lancer classée juste que souvent je
demande la pub à radio de battre le son
change de poste pendant tandis qu'une
pub comme les filets c'est que ça ralph
et où comme souvent le dernier pas de
casser comme
c'est qu'elle joue au pij a cessé comme
les smartphones
ont cessé mais colman les podcasts même
twinkle dans nos vies en tabarnak des
experts mettait des connaissances dans
seulement tous les domaines et je
pourrais je pourrais pas rouler mais
mettons moi maintenant je pourrai plus
rouler la technique comme tahar ould
bien plus probant que je peux parler de
charisme en plus fort que moi je peux
parler mais ma force rectificatif
réaliste je réalise je m'en viens quand
même pas payer ces gens les jeux de
trivium été
payés pour cela et écouter des affaires
puis apprendre à apprendre des trucs sur
plein de sujets différents ces facs et
sa cuisse et mais c'est sûr qu'il ya
aussi la maintenance il ya tellement peu
de casse des fois il est trop studio en
même temps qu'ils roulent il nous fait
le je pense qui d'après moi maintenant
je dois écouter moindre pas de casque et
j'en écoutais ya un mois juste parce que
notre set-up et chargé fonctionnement
changer pareil mais pareil mais là tu
peux choisir ce que tu écoutes exaltant
mais tout ceci n'est pas trop dangereux
max passe de pas trop de gestion et tu
peux choisir ce que tu écoutes couvrir
soit exact parce que des fois j'imagine
qu'il y en avait six étaient quand même
pour samedi n'écoutez pas de casse le
team
déclaré temps quand ça arrive un natif
ou moins par d'autres choses sur leur
part
j'écoute tout le temps à peu près
maintenant au moins au moins genre
d'accord tu peux te laissais pas être
capable d'un engin près aussi j'en suis
aussi un peu avec le monde pareil du 1
mai
mais ouais c'est sûr que tu puisses pas
parce que c'est pas parce que les
podcasts sont mauvais c'est juste parce
que c'est claire t pas de casse maton
qui parle de football si j'écoute djamel
football sauf une fois par année cette
dame près encore si je serai pas y avoir
de suivre de toute façon je ne connais
pas ce 6 mai
mais non je dis j'en écoute j'en écoute
encore pas mal quand même si j'aime
j'aime c'est la raison pour que je
réussisse et c'est ici je trouve ça n'a
pas de gaz dans le fond ce sera pas
changée
semaine
un beau
belle histoire mais le fait que tu
travailles ici maintenant parce que tu y
mets ton il te crées te crie ta job lui
lançant son temps accepté pendant 3 4 4
4 fois donné gratuitement nous aider en
faisant leur russell james au fait que
je vais mettre du temps gratuit
ce temps là finalement il était quand
même qu'ils soient revenues le pti je
parle encore mon abonnement pq en dix
ans l honneur saint-pierre sa vie je
m'étais fait encore le
steam et en mettant ton frère le pascal
le tiki fait moi je veux faire des films
c'est caen qui mène je veux aller
prendre leçon même sur une série et sous
y parce que genre c'est un guide qui
m'est proposé ça paye peau mais comme je
vais aller sur le plateau même donne un
coup de main et puis le décrire en
aiguille c'est qu'un match une bonne job
je trouve que c'est un bon exemple de
comme tu veux faire quelque chose
commence le djia prend des démarches men
participe bien que va tomber c'est une
job d'autres leur n'aurait probablement
pas nécessairement affiche une job
j'aurais
des recherches et techniciens de
podcasts le trip ici on l'avait appliqué
on aurait peut-être pas pris le temps ça
se ferait peut-être pas appliquer le
taux de ce fait comme un échec ça me
permettra là dedans fait que je vais me
rentrer dedans dans ce même pays
une question de circonstances aussi
contexte le tir au japon
j'étais là mais j'étais j'ai été
chanceux d'être là au bon moment si japy
dans le panier seul fait qui
fait rage en dessous de la proactivité
effectivement moutons d'installer aussi
tu te tais je t'assure piquionne puis si
je cotise pour une coupe la fermeture
mettons de
limogeage en permettant de l'annuler
plus je sais je payais pour tel autre
personne paye le steak le steve a tôt
fait enfin oui une question de chance
aussi des comme c'était le timing était
vraiment bon timing était fou le 6 mai
mais si je pense rester vraiment alerte
rester alerte à ce l'était de
houcine kharja qui
tombait dans l'ésotérisme quoique ce
soit les médecins c'est vrai que de
temps en temps dans vijaya desing gentil
qui arriva au puits puis je pense que
des fois juste d'y aller de ponyo racing
lou pitt font ces gens c'est même cette
foule payante que le pour moi
mais je ne serai jamais imaginé être
entendu si thibault artistes présentés
riscle c'est juste des comme catho une
affaire qui se présente le ja l'insep
avoir pigé disait l'autre jour j'ai
entendu
un dicton c'est juste le temps déjà
c'étaient les différences entre
les choses s'étaient différence entre
courir marathon puis pour courir le
marathon s'est couru un marathon
dans ce sens que tia manu en eau enfin
afin de construire faire de quoi en
train fou tu fasses repos se dit bon
choix pour toi c'est quand qu'ils
courent entre en action
c'est quelque chose que tout le temps
voulu faire citer et puis tu attends tu
attends attends ça va peut-être vous
soumettons les différences ans passés un
peu de casse pipe aux partis à la casse
s'est passé en podcast soit
le sens
commun est le seul all figo faisons le
sexe oral sait aussi c'est que ça râle
ça a pris entre le moment où est-ce
qu'on en a eu l'idée ben oui quand on a
décidé de le faire on a décidé d'aller
de l'avant et que ça a pris deux
semaines c'est à cannes et à peu près ça
a commencé mais toi tu aimais tant après
un maul il faut tout est pris les
concerts qu'ils ont tout à fait exact
exact qui
le studio si le centre exemple c'est
juste
faire les affaires des fois il ya du
monde qui attendent qu'ils à faire leur
arrive le team est temps que tu caresse
l'idée de former
de la musique mais tant que
tu le fais pas maintenant dia j'atteins
telle ou telle raison ou tel de la
forclaz ça arriverait jamais même si tu
prends pas sur toi tu le fais pas il
faut que tu fasses des affaires là
dessus toi même tu en as mis en tabarnak
du temps jean au studio à casser des
trucs même d'affaires qui était au début
pas nécessairement bon avant de
commencer à être maîtrisé le shit de là
à voir des jeunes tu le fais tu sais pas
pas nécessairement d'argent d'avoir des
gens qui apprécient font quand même que
tu puisses te papa le mariam qui
décident de travailler avec toi tu le
sais comme l acquis mais non fan de
cette affaire propulse à son peuple le
ya du monde qui va leur travail actuel
d'autre d'autres d'autres le parce que
tu as passé calmement dit à pop ayant à
faire ce oui mais
n'empêche que
c'est des choses j'ai travaillé fort
mais la plupart des choses qui me sont
arrivées sont arrivés parce que
justement je devenu bon mais c'est
quelque chose que les membres approché
dit merci c'est énorme mais c'est normal
mais ouais mais sauf que met-on mais
tant que moi secrètement je caresse
l'idée de sortir un album depuis 1 10 à
1 en fait non mais tu quart est/sud-est
sortir d'album depuis dix ans le poteau
mais c'est fait les
métros la revue alors gesti genre j des
réunions d'affaires dans la juge a aussi
comme je fais pas de la place pour ce je
m'organise peu comme j'ai pas les
actions nécessaires pour que j'en parle
dans le concret il étape avant ce sens
par vous c'est quoi le satan roumaine
faut le faire face
satan satis attentes un peu j'aime dans
le fond la team a même battu le regrette
pas ma tante du genre à asseoir mathon
c'est ce que je fais c'est vraiment de
la musique que je fais peu importe ce
qui se passe peu importe à quel point je
fatigue et jean raquin jarry de la job
ou peu importe là c'est ce que je fais
mais je te garantis que le soir quand tu
coches
lorsqu'elle mais c'est facile de tomber
dans ce genre de routine nos deux comme
tout est bon tout ph est quelqu'un qui
fait kiffer les enfants c'est maintenant
qu'on est et où et quand faisait sur la
cuisine on utilise déjà on préfère genre
un studio qui on préfère comme
une compagnie genre de production de
podcasts qui produit des pâtes gaspille
louis studio danois l'a jeté comme
huawei sera une bonne bouille ont reçu
ainsi comme
on
sait comme mais il ya fort que justin
pas ce genre de projet de nom non parce
que ça sinon ça prend la place dans ma
tête ça me fait chier je mets mes
méthodes c'est une affaire je me trompe
je reprends l'exemple du pic à la même
compagnie que j'ai lancé le tiens ça
fait la seconde j'ai pensé j'ai mis en
action des trucs pour commencer à créer
et à cri le dossier dit souvent souvent
on se trouve des raisons pour pas
commencé et puis maintenant le studio le
dirigeant après année je peux tu te
rappelles dessus on est allé au
starbucks mettons le puits sur starbucks
proche de chez vous à dans une cycle
peloton avec comme tu avais comme
dresser la liste des genres
financièrement qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'ils pouvaient faire du sancy si on se
fie aime et on a la liste initiale avait
dressé on lançait pas le studio y avait
rien et viable dans dans ce projet lotis
mais on aurait pu utiliser ça comme
excuse de dirigeants rebelles chez
convoi on va rester dans ces trop de
risques et c'est trop dangereux les
chiffes adopte pas maintenant on aurait
pu prendre ça faire comme non mais non
on se lance pas parce que cech temps
marche pas au dessus mais il ya quelque
chose comme
autre chose que le calcul cartésien puis
j'ai l'impression que c'était juste une
raison c'est parce qu'au final ce
quelque chose fonctionne ce retard est
tu vas tu as rangé pour ça fonctionne si
mettons du pic en ce moment là je me
verse pas de salaire
renversée avant un instit boîte parce
que tout l'argent de la sphère dollar
investi mais si tu arrives dans le
projet pts 10
voici deux ans sans salaire c'est l'amer
raison pour faire je me lance pas là
dedans j'ai l'impression que souvent sur
les gens sont peints sommes prêts à
prendre du temps pour rémunérer surtout
de nos jours le théâtre sans filtre si
au début on se dit ah faut que ce soit
rémunéré mensah que l'on va connaître
notre premier add ça a pris un genre de
30 épisodes de 30 épisodes qui se
demande si ces trois corps d'une année
l'été où est-ce qu'on est l eur puis à
chaque fois king's men ont monté le set
up tout je faisais du montage même de
commun ça doit être prendre un deux
heures par semaine juste faire le
montage de minimum le plus le mixage
pour rémunérer 0 le tir mais on ne peut
pas utiliser cette excuse pour ne pas
recommencer mais il ya quelque chose
aussi dans le le concept de ces deux
semaines dans marque pourra compléter
trois c'est parce que t'as pas le choix
de la fin d'année cit et cit est dans
merde justement dit tu es moi je me
cache pas universités matin j'étais
quand même genre bon procrastinateurs
impro les impros la procrastination
c'est jeter quand même pas pire la dame
et je fonctionnais vraiment par contre
je fonctionnais vraiment là dedans puis
c'est clame à paul le truc le plus haï
de gens vraiment peu mais mais ça risque
quand je t'ai force affaire de courage
apache tu es vraiment la semaine depuis
que je suis donné un monstre et je
voudrais pas que tu es meilleur mais
j'en suis quasiment comme comme suis
capable j'ai une idée de voir où je veux
aller mettons dans var où je vais aller
piller ou ckac sports puis par ou qui
part ou que je vais passer pour me
rendre dans mon travaux matonti fait que
puis j'en parlais avec une de mes amies
a pas longtemps mais tu l'écho adversité
ironisé
elcaman cas précis c'est un cours à foix
mais mettons sur trois semaines c'est un
gros blast
dans une amphore super précis
puis pis pour moi ça fait du sens parce
que moi justement tu es dans ma vie mais
ton jeu fonctionne j'ai tout genre de
checklists dents
en aucune manière je fais ce tchèque
après sa soeur après ceux ci après ce
succès si le même phénomène que j'arrive
à fonctionner mais audrey de la façon
que c'est fait après en ce moment c'est
que c'est comme tu dois vous les plans
d'affaires en simultané un peu puis au
final comme à long terme tu arrives tu
arrives tu es pop faut tout cas taillé
fini mais je trouve que d'être capable
de
compartimenter sera en fait justement
puis de se dire qu'il a pendant trois
semaines je me concentre uniquement là
dessus mais je le finisse et je le finis
pas passer des messages en faire un
autre mais se sait c'est à double
tranchant aussi parce que mettons
souvent dans vie va falloir avancer
plusieurs dossiers en méditative puis un
bon ami à moi je viens à one qui venu
sur le podcast
l'épisode je me rappelle pas l'épisode
est à l'écouté sont pas de casque qui
s'appelle journal d'un entrepreneur
c'est vraiment solide dans plein de
conseils sur ce que lui ce qui me dit en
mai puis c'est quelque chose qui m'a
marqué ce qui m'a marqué beaucoup qui
marque beaucoup et dans la gestion du
studio mais dans la gestion aussi du pic
en ce moment c'est de dire y'a pas de
deux priorités up bcd mettons dans ce
que tu fais faut que tu le vois il ya un
os 2 o 3 au 4 fecteau d autant
prioritaire faut juste les avances en
même temps c'est faux tout avance en
même temps trois cabanes mandataire de
voir super de l'avancé en même temps
puis mois l'université ça m'a permis de
faire ça m'a permis de développer cette
capacité de faire comme ok le
g4 à faire qu'on le mans différentes
quatre dossiers complément différent
qu'il faut que j'avance en même temps à
la même intensité puis pour être capable
d'arriver à un résultat qui va être le
meilleur dans chacun des affaires pense
que si mettons le site et comme ce
probablement qu'on aurait on serait
peut-être paralysé par une pluralité de
dossiers à gérer mais dont la vie c'est
plusieurs dossiers à gérer le site et
c'est toute une semaine des dossiers le
cet été tu vas en avoir en tabarnak
algérie tu peux pas juste de dire
maintenant qu'il doit apprendre justice
est cette liste là parce que tu as trois
tournées en même temps que ses cartes
fauchois capable d'évoquer avec du roi
mais aussi de quand même l'obr capable
d'accompagner rien de plus comme des
apports faute chante en jouant la baisse
plus le robot sait si comme tandis que
si tu disais acquis l'oeuvre je veux
faire un album hands d'instrumental
pendant un mois tout seul chez vous
l'opecst je pourrais le forum et on
s'est peut-être sur la différence et
peut-être d'être capable de faire des
moments dans la vie où est ce que tu es
capable de faire ça mais de dire aussi
avec éloge bloquent trois semaines où
est ce que je suis dans mon studio puis
que je ne fais que
ce matin je file me clinton enfin pas de
kaspersky
trop fort mais mais oui mais après ce
que tu veux faire de quoi comme
justement faire la bonne partie vraiment
un projet
il faut aussi commander du bloc du temps
ce blog du temple qui te concentres sur
qu'il mène dans un espace créatif
mettons - mais oui parce que tu sais ça
prend son temps enfin bonne affaire
plutôt qu'être presser pour faire comme
12 mai la femme defossez
moi j'ai l'impression que j'ai
l'impression à dire et je fonctionne
plus comme ceux de céline
c'est je pense la raison pourquoi je
prêt qu'à signer un prêt universités
c'est un peu ça dans le fond parce que
la maman n'était plus loin c'est soit ça
soit pas d'autre à faire que tu peux
faire puis le lendemain ça va être fait
quasi direct factice j'encourage pas
sincèrement jamais est vrai que moi pour
moi ça fonctionne et ses pigments
même et on attend créativement genre
qu'un cash fait de la musique les
meilleurs trucs ça va être les trucs qui
vont sortir genre d'engin une journée
qu'ils toucheraient pas avant de
m'arrêter je vais juste valeur travail
est arrivé mais leroy sow mais souvent
mettons les trucs que j'ai fait ce
que j'ai fait ma temps je travaillais
d'un trois heures la tuque après ce
genre avait deux jours plus tard grâce à
un petit joue à dire et ça pour moi ça
marche pas je ne mange pas tant que
roche fini par avoir un paquet projet
différent mais il y en a plein qui sont
pas finies la dent ou je me ramasse avec
un nombre tourne m est un genre de
ramare sud un peu l'ordre
c'est comme plus existants
pour moi maintenant de commencer quelque
chose plus chine dit c'est quand même un
lycée comme si les étapes entre
commencer le truc puis l'amener à à sa
finalité je me tanne
apporte justement les affaires que le
jeu des comptes à rendre demande que
j'ai pas chouette de boulot mais de
garder le focus sur quelque chose mais
te donne un objectif qui dimanche tu
fais ce de le faire jusqu'au bout'' ces
cellules ce but offre pour moi le plus
important
c'est ça c'est le sait le 81 80 % du
travail fait pour 20% des forts le
dernier vingt pour cent qui demandent 80
% du travail c'est comme si c'est cela
c'est ça l'amour dita von teese
faire un film avant l'idée d'un film et
y est ça va dans l'offensive en donnant
des lézards géants pile ce qu'il soit
facile à voir genre douze mille idées de
films de genre tellement d'étapes en
tram l'idée d'un film qu'un film fini
que genre si ça prend de l'endurance il
faut que
pitié non c'est ça même si c'est
tellement d affaires de longue haleine
qui épie de l'eau vient l'importance de
je ne sais pas si si si dans notre
bibliothèque là mais le livre que je
devais passer je postulais l'avez lu de
haruki murakami
autoportrait de l'auteur en coureur de
fond plus comment les explications des
plus grands auteurs au monde puis
comment expliques tu travailles lui
c'est qui compare sa son entraînement
pour un marathon puis 10 à chaque matin
je me lève je fais trois heures
d'écriture
peu importe qu est ce qui se passe je
puis à chaque matin quand additionne
toutes ces horreurs mais temps de
travail en un an tu peux en faire en
tabarnak des city vous autres là chaque
matin bentley tu fais trois heures de
composition je te garantis que dans un
entre un album puis ça se peut qu'au
début de ce genre tu vois la tâche
men c'est une scène la tâche de composer
un album si tu y vas trois ans à chaque
fois king jouet même ton album la menace
avait écrit il je vais écrire un roman
le genre structure vraiment si tu écris
trois heures des fois ça va être trois
heures que tu gardais faut trois heures
que tu gardes pas mais si à chaque matin
tu te lèves tu fais trois heures même
une arme et on le sait à chaque matin tu
te lèves tu fais une heure d'écriture
ben men après un an tu vas avoir quelque
chose tiens à le oui c'est long mais
c'est pas si l'on se dit les demandes
tous l'impression genre histoire d'un
roman est sorti écrive une série
d'impressions qui est beau mais si lyon
sud ils font juste le faire chaque jour
il faut le faire à chaque jour en natif
et ce quelqu'un qui sort un album par
annick site internat qui arrêtent peau
mais non on dit david goudreault une des
seules dix sont nés qui sont son livre
tamment à moi et le com écrit jam a pris
trop au risque à chaque jour je m'étais
temps à écrire qu'à fin dans le roman on
ramasse a peut paraître une scène
commence une charge de travail mais
différente à chaque jour comme si
s'entraîner ce même principe tu
t'entraînes pour un marathon pour un
ultra c'est comme ça là il faut que tu
fasses manager 4000 km dans ton année
ouais mais à chaque jour tu te lèves et
tu t'en fille qui
s'est trouvée sont trouvés son momentum
c'est le truc le plus le plus important
au final dans n'importe quoi str
dernière bon dans n'importe quoi ce jeu
doit être capable de
de t'asseoir pu le faire mais à
répétition longtemps c'est je pense ce
qui est
clairement tu l'as pris genre avec le
sport et de la sport là dessus je pense
aux autres c'est une zone c'est plus la
musique dans le fond aussi j'ai appris
le sport j'ai transféré à musique après
avoir sévi tout a commencé la natation
seront sauvés mais mais ouais je pense
ce spleen c'est la discipline cet été
john petrucci kim tillie et ce sont ces
tubes sont des deux
[Rires]
c'est clair je reviens l'idée d'être
bardos et accomplir des trucs
que je connais mais ton crissement avant
lui fait l'enregistrement puis lors du
mixage puis sur la réalisation de tous
ni vraiment bon
mais genre
il vient d'une famille vraiment riche
dont près de ses parents genre ip tout
genre une allocation à chaque chaque mot
a déjà été fait qui peut juste dire là
dessus
ça coût final
y opposent en l'espèce de départ et
point l'usc de fin de travaux si je fais
pas sûr si je peux déjà excellente cij a
su bien je peux pas manger mettons
qu'il freine on était des fois faut
continuer dans ce sens un peu dans la
marde tout connaître il faut que genre
si c'est comme ça marche pas
tu es nous mettons que j'allais tout en
musique je me suis archi jeter dessus 6
ans nat musique ou sciences humaines
musée comme je me garde des portes
ouvertes mais gare du canet saïd line je
m'écarte une job à côté c'est comme non
jeudi comme s'est notamment plaint eux
dati qui
s'y implantent décès des bébés nés
chance que le plan au site offre au
caire c'est ça la frappe ça c'est un
cliché qu'on répète souvent les gens pas
de plan b mais tant pis mais ce qui met
crise c'est vraiment parce que
puis le plan il va être top le plan
voire des mamans les teens on a vécu
sous le pied des moments où est ce que
tu fais comme au tabarnak genre là je
pense ça y est je pense que c'est d'elle
le truc est mort mais là c'est quand
même inquiet mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour pas que ça arrive puis
l'europe change un peu le tanking change
le truc re manage un peu plus calmes à
qui on vient de trouver une solution qui
fait que ça marche puis sa 6e dans
tootsie topol le plan b pour faire c'est
rotov fox eu honte on laisse tomber
dessus
avec pour faire un handicap de tout seul
et c'est
lance ton truc même fait le jazz jazz de
bonne foi la différence est parfois plus
facile de faire cesser pourrez
pratiquer tout les jours constance puis
work
nicky merci tellement même deux pour
cesser tout ça c'est pas de casse mais
ça nous le plaisir le plaisir et pour
moi c'est une perle mendes c'est une
autre affaire aussi que j'ai discuté
avec avec julien puis on tente de
compliments quand me
sens généralement
ça nous empêche de monter ton salaire on
fait juste rentrer lambert qui disaient
les uns police en foot salaires et
veulent juste de se sentir accompli
quelques mois mais non mais non c'est
pas vrai mais c'est pop c'est pas vrai
si c'est exact faut non plus puisque
c'est sans aucun doute je sais la place
puis le moment dans ma vie je pense que
j'ai je reçois le plus de l'oeuvre le
délit de tout le monde qui de vous
autres qui des facs et nice mais ça me
dégoûte mais qui présente rue quand mais
si vous attendez des employeurs aux
entrepreneurs le
vous employez le trouvais pas trouvé un
des bons parce que le nombre de cas
steinmann pi2 de shit qui arrive est
comme qui aurait tomber dans notre
assiette si tu étais moi et me ton
indépendant puis proactif le ses
innombrables genre d affaires d
astaffort que je faisais je suis ni qui
peut tout gérer surplus de nikki om en
hausse cruellement de cube c'est comme
ça ça a tout changé le thé l'emploi du
mot à chaque modèle
jusqu'à faut tout même cadre et 48
fautes aujourd'hui
et puis encore à ce jour
le je sais pas combien de temps qu'on a
lancé le studio pitt est avec nous deux
ans à peu près deux ans et demi
on n'a pas perdu un podcast
on n'a pas perdu un podcast de toutes
les études y ait des podcasts en
tabarnak sont enregistrés s'ils n'ont
pas perdu en main ça serait drôle que ce
soit se l'imaginent
way allez merci nick evans evra cool ça
fait plaisir les gars toujours plaisir
c'est encore mon petit préféré encaisser
un coup job c'est beau